- [Narrator] Biatches!
- Ham bump!
(farting)
(class groaning)
- Excuse me, Ms. Klitnick is
in a BM today, a bad mood.
Not one guy has winked at me
on PlentyOfGefilteFish.com
I'm feeling less than.
Why don't you kids practice
writing writing the number five.
(sniffling)
(class groaning)
- Danglers, see ya.
- [Woman] Woohoo, my
period's late, lover.
- I feel bad for Ms. Klitnick.
- Why don't you do
reverse cowgirl with her?
(laughing)
- I want love.
- Seriously Dana, what
can we do to help her?
- I know!
Let's catfish her.
Follow my weinerbush.
(crying)
(keyboard clicking)
- Ooh!
- Let's make a fake
profile so we can wink
at Ms. Klitnick to
make her feel better.
Who's picture should we use?
- It's gotta be
someone believable.
- (gasps) Barack Obama.
- [Julia] (gasps) Yeah.
- Want to love you.
(beeping)
Oh my god, Julia, she got it.
- (gasps) Oh my god, it's her.
Let's meet at the Lazy Latke
at 3:00 p.m. to see
if we have chemistry.
P.S. I won't have time to
shave so don't judge me.
Dana, we can't do this.
- Oh yeah! (laughs)
- See you there.
(laughing)
(beeping)
- Class dismissed early today!
#blessed, #grateful.
- Now what do we do?
- We just gotta find a
single guy to meet her.
- Your dad's single.
- Gross.
- And your dad is a yoga
teacher so he has an open heart.
- Shut your mouth.
- And if it's a love connection,
we can spy on your dad
and Ms. Klitnick humping.
- Boom!
(phone ringing)
- Well namaste my
little karma ball.
Of course I'd love to
talk to Ms. Klitnick
about the importance
of breath work.
- Mr. Goodman!
I didn't realize it was you.
- It's me, but please
call me Govindas.
(breathing)
- I've never done this before.
- Not to worry, we're
in this together.
♪ Can you make me
go ooh ooh, ooh ah
♪ Do you think you can touch me
- Wow, you have
really soft hands.
- Truth be told, I
use a mashugana amount
of petroleum jelly to
moisturize my skins.
- Why don't we
get right into it?
Follow my breath.
(heavy breathing)
(shouting)
Wow, our chakras opened
up at the same time.
- I feel so connected to you.
- I haven't felt this connected
to someone since
Dana's mother died.
- (sniffs) I don't want
Ms. Klitnick to be my mom.
- Don't cry poopy pie,
your mom was the best.
Ms. Klitnick can
never replace her.
Look, Ms. Klitnick's underwear.
(laughing)
- What?
Who?
- Look at me, Dottie.
(moaning)
- That was a straight
up mitzvah y'all.
You're good girls trying to
take care of old Ms. Klitnick.
(smooching)
(laughing)
- Ham bump!